live local now and thanks for joining us
here at 11 o'clock i'm denise feldas and
i'm brian loftis by the time a legion
stadium marks five years since opening
there's a chance it could have already
hosted a super bowl the nfl is planning
meetings this week to talk about a host
site for the game coming up in 2024 and
madison kimbrough live near the stadium
tonight with more on what bringing the
super bowl to las vegas would mean for
our city
you know whether you're a sports fan or
not you've got to give it up for vegas
for being the entertainment capital of
the world and now soon becoming a sports
staple within the community and with the
potential of hosting super bowl 58 here
at allegiant locals all around are
thrilled at what this means for our city
las vegas has never been like a sports
type of place and so i just think that's
really cool that we're just becoming
that with now like golden knights and
just like a whole like football team i
think that's really cool super bowl 58
could potentially have a new home here
in las vegas while an official
announcement has yet to be made the
league's owners could share news as
early as wednesday if vegas does land
the hosting gig in 2024 all eyes will be
on allegiant stadium for the big game
and while sports fans are pumped this
also means big things for our city
economically i think it's definitely a
landmark moment for the city of las
vegas in the state of nevada i think
it's going to have two impacts the first
is the actual visitation
when the super bowl is here i think more
than that it's going to boost las vegas
profile even more than it already is and
get new eyes in the city a local
business that has benefited greatly from
the addition of allegiant stadium says
they are ready for the big day even if
it is over two years away with them
coming with the super bowl i mean even
with the raiders in general here on
sundays it has made our business grow
tremendously there isn't a better
combination football and barbecue and
beer come on that's a great sunday there
now as for other nfl events set to take
place here at the stadium we've got the
pro bowl that's in february and then the
nfl draft that's going to be in late
april reporting live at allegiant
stadium madison kimbrough live local now
now we do want to point out new orleans
was supposed to host what would have
been super bowl 58 that year but mardi
gras created a conflict because the nfl
went to a 17 game schedule if las vegas
gets the game that year new orleans
would then get it in 2025